it is the beetle really responsible for
pushing the Canadian timber firms to the
US it's been a big factor but what west
fraser meticulous say they're the ones
is willing to talk about this on the
record they said that it really
accelerated their move into the u.s. it
wasn't the only factor it just made them
do it faster one of the other impacts it
had was to make their milling operations
a lot more efficient back in the day
they'd throw away all the off cuts all
the bart that's been stripped from these
trunks now they're using them things
like biomass down in the u.s. you have a
huge demand in housing that fell off in
the late 2000s 2008-2009 that's picked
up again they want to be near the market
that's the important thing for them as
well now obviously beetles in this case
the mountain pine beetle does not
recognize national borders so what does
this mean for the timber industry in the
United States and we were seeing
outbreaks in Colorado in parts of the
Northwest Pacific Northwest where there
are big lumber operations as well and
the Canadians really concerned that it's
now cross the Rockies successfully into
Alberta and could potentially continue
spreading as far as the Atlantic coast
does this mean that the supplies when
you mention how they're beefing up the
operations in order to take advantage of
the fact that they can get them lumber
out now but where's the replacement
going to come from the trees ring it's a
60 70 80 year timeline they're looking
at so although the government might say
for 5-10 years yes cut as much as you
can right now so we can get the
economics out of these trees that
otherwise will be killed by the Beatles
the long-term effect of that is that
they will not be that supply down the
road and they're gonna have to look at
different species and of course
different locations which is one of the
reasons that down in the US now